[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting
we're getting into part two of sex
timber in this episode in particular we
are talking about what it's like to be
two
boys
turning into men
and all the confusion that comes along
with that basically just you know you
know sexual stuff in the context of
purity culture we are not currently boys
becoming men but we're gonna go back and
walk through our house
completely
that's true especially after maybe some
of the
uh
criticism that was that that came from
last week's episode i don't know we're
recording this before the for last
week's comes out so there's some
conjecture but we're going to talk
through
our high school experience and college
experience leading up to
i don't know i i think leading up to but
not including
our first time having sex which for each
of us was on our wedding night
with our wives unless there's something
wedding nights we each have a wedding
night yeah you do unless there's
something you haven't told me that maybe
you'll tell me today
did you lose your virginity is that even
a thing
hmm
oh well teeth that's a good teaser yeah
purity culture we'll get in all that
we'll also describe what it is but i
mean first you should sing
the theme song oh give it another chance
okay uh i don't really sex timber
if you
like the idea of two straight cis white
dudes talking about sex
and the fact that they waited until they
got married to have sex
and
this is coming from a very particular
perspective of these two dudes who are
not trying to be prescriptive about all
the stuff that they're saying they're
just kind of telling their story and
trying to be honest
about sex if you're into that idea
tune in for sex timber
it's happening now oh that's good that
was good i like that yeah that's good
yeah this is it
there's no real cadence or a rhyme
scheme
uh in fact i don't think any of that
rhymed there weren't a lot of notes
either it's probably a kind of probably
a great metaphor for
this entire exercise kind of pounding
okay
i do want to say before we move into
today's episode that
having only recorded
episode one yeah
that was all about our uh
you know first thoughts about sex
and then first in a sex talk or not
and then moving into like our
introduction to what sex was and how we
kind of pieced that together i bet you
they remember uh
by the way hashtag ear biscuits continue
to let us know uh what you think and
also send us your sex questions
or things you would like for us to
discuss in episode after next
yeah
uh i gotta say i've been i've been
struggling
uh i've never been i've never been that
honest about sex publicly
i've never i've never told i never have
told anyone
maybe besides my own wife the the story
of the first time i masturbated yeah so
there's i i was filled with and still am
a little bit like filled with this
trepidation of having been so honest
about it
without really thinking about
you know like again the whole point of
this this whole exercise
is to just put another point on the
perspective out there of two guys who
come from this particular background
we're not trying to tell you what to
think about anything we're just telling
you this is our story this is what we
thought but because we've never taken
the time to be this honest or vulnerable
about anything
that well this
this sort of you know about sex
something that is there's just so much
stigma attached to a stigma stigma
attached to it not only within
uh christian culture but just culture in
general right that i'm just i'm like man
even though we warn people and we
continue to warn you if you're
uncomfortable with the idea of us
talking explicitly about sex do not
listen to this do not you know because
that is unless you own unless you're
like yes i want to be uncomfortable
but did i make people feel so
uncomfortable who decided to listen that
now they're forever they forever see me
differently or like i said something and
i had no idea how it was going to be
interpreted again i haven't seen the
response yet and so so i was literally
sitting there that night thinking oh man
should i just edit that whatever i
talked about how
much i liked vagina i needed i needed we
need i got to go back and take that out
i thought about a few things that i said
and that you said and i lost a couple of
weeks of sleep over it um
i don't know it's out there now and it
is what it is um and
uh i think that
yeah there is a bit of a fear of like is
something going to come out wrong or
have an unintentional
effect
um
or is it
is it going to hurt somebody is it going
to grow somebody is it going to change
someone's view of you or
me
in a way that
like
i don't know that it that evokes elicits
judgment i think it's kind it's part of
the fear too
it's like oh this
now now he means this to to me
like this is my opinion of him has
changed it could be me it could be you
you know and probably me i'm just
concerned so yeah i have been concerned
that
uh
somebody might not know that
i don't know i just don't know i did you
know we can't be
oh god
well let's just let's just keep going
you just never know we you know it's
it's an interesting time the thing that
we want to do as you said is
help to dismantle the stigma around
having
open
responsible adult conversations around
the topic of sex sexuality
and
um
the good and bad and the ugly of it but
we're only
we're only doing that through telling
our experiences
and again
i hope that it will be
two points of view for anyone listening
to take into account
but never
i never hope or expect that someone's
just gonna listen to what we say even if
we do give an opinion
and just say okay i'm
i agree with that hook line and sinker
right you know it's i and that's what
i'm trusting we want that to be true of
this podcast in general but i'm tr i'm
true it's a real test i'm trying to
trust the process
you know but uh and i do think that one
of the things that
we're trying to keep in mind and we
would love for you to keep in mind as
well especially as we get into talking
about
purity culture this week
is that um
you know nothing that we're we're
actually trying to be conscious of this
about your biscuits in general right and
especially this is a note from me more
than it's a no for link because i tend
to get
i tend to go into like prescriptive
advice mode and i tend to go into like
persuasion mode
it's my personality
and but i don't
want neither of us want this podcast to
be
about that you know this is not a
well-researched podcast unless the
research is
the life that we have lived right
uh this is kind of a
uh this is a conversation between two
friends that the internet is invited to
be a part of and so we speak from our
perspective and we know that our
perspective is specific
as we said in the theme song but also we
also know that our perspectives have
evolved enough over time to preserve the
right to change our minds and to
continue to grow
as people yeah and even as we talk about
something like purity culture in the
context of like evangelic the way
evangelicals think or we we thought
in that context about sex we're not here
to
indict
that now some of the things that we say
will be
indicting because that's our perspective
but that's that's not the
point is to be like and here's why this
is bad and that's the point of this
episode it's like no
if you are doing your own research about
what you think about sex and what you
think about purity culture
here's another data point for you
as we give our own personal perspective
but we're not trying to give our opinion
uh
and i think that maybe in the fourth
episode when we get into answering
questions we may get into a little bit
more of like well okay you asked me what
i thought about this i'm gonna tell you
uh but this we're trying to kind of keep
this centered around telling our story
yeah i do want to lay the groundwork for
what purity culture is
so i'm just going to lay that pipe yeah
there you go right now
so
the purity culture
is a
a 90s evangelical movement
that
discouraged dating and promoted
virginity
until marriage
and it did that through what i'll call
gimmicks
uh purity pledges purity rings purity
dances like father-daughter dances they
call them balls actually purity balls
yeah
yeah that's the only ball you can have
girl
the purity ball um
and
there's so it's
it's seeking to take what the bible
teaches
about purity and sexual immorality
and apply it
especially to developing preteens and
teens and
as it exploded on the scene
in like the early 90s
we it was directed at us
like we
we fully experienced it as the target
demo
of of purity culture
and
the biblical roots of it there's there's
a couple of there's a couple of
teachings that that at least stand out
for me and my memory and as i like did
did a little bit of dusting off the
my my bible on google and a couple of
articles
but there's this principle that
your body is a temple of god that
god
in the form of the holy spirit actually
lives within with inside of each
christian
and so a pledge of chastity to remain a
virgin until you get married
uh
is is a form of
uh allegiance and
or love for god and worship of god
and saying okay my body
is
like
god's living with inside
inside of me there is there's
there's places where
paul talks about
if you take
if you take your body and then you go to
a and you unite with a prostitute if you
have sex with a prostitute you're
basically bringing
god into that equation
and that is not a good thing
that is a that is a sinful thing so
that's that's the first part of it is
that
there's this
god's within inside of you don't do
anything that is is wrong because you're
you're bringing god along for the ride i
guess no pun intended
the second point is that when it comes
to sex
there's
this mis they never use the term
mystical that's how i would describe it
now but i'm going to describe it as a
there's a mystical component to sex
where
um
you have a you a soul bond
with somebody that you actually have sex
with um in genesis it talks about
uh
the two shall become one flesh talking
about adam and eve like
that's the reason why
uh
you should leave your father and mother
and cleave to your wife
or husband
and so when you get married and when you
consummate that marriage in sex
there is some
some mystical
joining your souls are literally
intermingling and then you've got paul
talking about things like well and
apparently the soul goes directly
through the penis into the vagina i mean
just to be frank about it and maybe one
called how else does it happen i think
the female cell comes out of the vagina
and then they like become become one the
two shall become one yeah i was just
speaking from the male perspective but i
yes yeah i think it goes both ways and
of course
all of this is
within the context of
a heterosexual
relationship only right you know maybe
that goes without saying
in terms of talking about this
evangelical movement but
uh i wanted to point that out too
so there's there are these biblical
teachings that again in the same way
that when we talked about our
deconstruction episodes there was this
there's this foundational principle of
you're you're born sinful and separated
from god and you're destined for hell
unless you accept
jesus payment for your sins his death
and resurrection on your behalf so that
then you can have
uh
an active relationship with god
and eternal life with him and escape
hell
so that foundational principle of hell
is in
it within the purity culture there's
it's that is akin to
once you have sex with somebody you're
you're
you're giving up a part of yourself
you're doing something that separates
you from god
and dan and potentially
or
i don't think
the takeaway was that it was potential
it was that it was actually damaging to
you for giving up that part of yourself
and so
that's kind of like
the the biblical underpinning as far as
far as i remember it but there was also
um you know a lot of practical
motivations the
the
the people who came up with this
movement
and then it went through the southern
baptist
with uh with all the
the purity events and rings and all of
that marketing stuff
these are these are
children of the 60s of the
sexual revolution and then you've got
aids is i mean
within a certain demographic
a lot of people are dying from aids and
there's sti other stis floating around
and teen pregnancy is is a shocking
problem
that people just want to get a handle on
it
so it was a confluence of taking
biblical teaching about purity
and combining it with
with things that we wanted to protect
our parents wanted to protect their
children from
and being informed maybe by the sexual
revolution
and just saying okay if
from a practical standpoint if i can
keep my kids from getting an sti or
uh
becoming pregnant and we just called we
just called it a std yeah we did we
didn't even call it what hadn't even
happened yet so protecting them from
that protecting them from uh unwanted
pregnancy teen pregnancy
and also protecting kids from heartbreak
that goes to all the way to the core of
your soul
i mean it it it felt to us as we were
experiencing this teaching
it had it carried just as much weight
as going to hell or not or almost as
much
that that's what i'm saying and i think
that it was um
for most christian teens
it was the most applicable sort of moral
teaching because
you know
let's face it
not a lot of christian kids were doing
drugs i mean some of them were
but the it was easier it was much easier
to avoid drug use
even alcohol
use
than it was to ignore the constant
horniness that we were all experiencing
right you know this is something you
don't wake up every single day and be
like i i need lsd you know it's like but
you do wake up every morning
uh look well sometimes literally you
know with an erection
you know so it's like you're you're
faced with this desire on a constant
basis and so i yeah i i think what
you're getting at is that
and also you said the 90s i think that
obviously the idea oh purity had been
around for a while but it it took on a
new
focus and structure there was a market
effectiveness there was a marketing plan
that was launched in the early 90s
that
had uh with the purity ring and the
purity pledge
and the purity balls all that stuff
happened then and get what you're
getting at with the the sort of the
complexity of this whole thing which i
think will kind of come out as we keep
talking about it and how we think about
it now and especially oh news flash hey
we're bringing
our wives in kiko we haven't told you
this we're bringing them in via a phone
call which we'll work out the tech on
that not to freak you out right now but
the lives will be coming in next episode
uh via the phone
and um we're gonna give them a ring we
will uh
maybe begin to explore this but this is
it there's a lot of complexity to this
because
all of religion and all of sort of
religious framework for the most part is
still designed like the people who are
adhering to it and the people who are
trying to implement it in their families
and with their children
most people are doing it out of a of a
motivation of love and what they believe
that's right most everyone
is motivate motivated by doing what they
actually think is right even though
their actions may be interpreted as
hateful and they may be hateful and they
may be harmful they don't see it as hate
and they don't see it as harmful they
see it as this is the best good and this
is what society should have and so and
in obedience to god it's not something
that in their minds they're making up
even though there's certainly a lot of
extrapolation beyond what the bible
actually says
to what
the practices they put in place i mean
there's no purity ball ring
or pledge in the bible uh but there's
you know concepts like
losing your virginity um
and a lot of analogies came out of the
movement in order to get these
what i'll call
good-hearted results like it's
good-hearted motives to get good results
but you've got these like analogies like
rose pet like pulling the petals off a
rose petal in order to help middle
school kids understand what happens when
you are deflowered you're deflowering
you can't put those petals back on that
flower no you can't and who who else
would want that flower that flower's
ruined i mean analogies like
chewed up gum who wants to who wants to
rechew chewed up gum these are actual
things that were techniques that were
taught almost always these analogies
refer to the woman which is very common
it is the woman who suffers
the brunt of purity culture and she's
the one that is the flower and she's the
one that's the chewed up gum there's a
double standard
and
the the principle of whatever you
do with someone that you're dating and
that you don't marry you're robbing your
future mate of that
experience
um and that ultimately
there's this message of if you do
something you shouldn't do
then you're damaged goods
and
then and then maybe
you know what and you know what that's
why jesus died and you're forgiven and
you need to experience grace and you
need to
and you can move forward but
it's kind of like when you say part a
that tends to stick in your mind a lot
more than the grace part b does
and i think that ultimately a lot of
people and i we can talk about our own
experiences there's a takeaway of fear
of something happening
spiritually physically or otherwise and
shame associated with everything that is
act that you're actually dealing with
and trying to discover and develop
through so i
i will say that
there's a there's an entire spectrum of
people who grew up like we did
under purity culture
who
have now landed in different places
about how grateful they are for it or
how damaged
they are by it
and and and so i i just want to
acknowledge that that
maybe
that
there could be some really ugly parts of
it and then there there can be some
parts that are really
uh
that could be helpful and it it varies
from person to person and i feel like
i'm
i'm somewhere in the middle on that
spectrum you know i've experienced some
good and some bad
but i know that it's been a lot worse
for other people and some people
they maybe they still swear by it i
guess
um
but one thing i'll add to that before we
get into you know talking about our
stories
um
is that i do while these are two points
on our perspective i do think that there
is some compelling sort of holistic
uh
data in the like how how effective is it
in telling kids these things and trying
to get kids to adhere to these things
when you think about
it it could be some other correlation
that i don't understand but i do find it
interesting
that a lot of these places where
culturally purity culture is very very
strong where there's a sort of
evangelical stronghold
tend to be places where there are also
high rates of teen pregnancy and stds or
sdis
uh you know whereas a lot of places that
kind of take a little bit more of a
secular approach where there's a lot of
sex education
and there's birth control those places
in sex you know in protected sex those
places tend to be like the northwest
there's less teen pregnancy and stis in
the northwest than there is in the
southeast you know so the studies are
out there uh yeah again that's not the
point of what we're talking about but i
just want to make
i think what you what you're ultimately
saying which i agree with is that we're
not here to say that every single thing
about it was bad we're going to give you
our perspective and talk about the ways
that we may have been damaged and the
way that we may have escaped some damage
whether or not we still adhere to any of
those beliefs
the the the sort of the spiritual
underpinning as we've made clear on this
podcast before we're we are not
christians we do not call ourselves
christians anymore we do not subscribe
to the ideas of purity culture we do not
have a biblical uh i do not have a
biblical world view when it comes to sex
and that's not what i teach my children
but
you know
i and i it's complex yep i'm coming from
the same place we're doing something new
and exciting this month using the
facebook live audio tool which is a new
tool that allows you to have a live
conversation as people kind of listen in
we're going to be talking to some
celebrity fathers about fatherhood about
parenthood and some of the lessons they
learned maybe exploring some different
aspects of that some things that we've
learned over the course of being fathers
for 18 and 17 years
so look out for that that's gonna be
over on the the mythical facebook page
yeah check it out and
while you're checking out stuff on the
internet go to the mythical amazon page
there's lots of stuff there that's
different
and fresh or
rejuvenated i don't know you'll have to
check it out all the stuff the
amazon.com mythical you can get that
prime shipping on some stuff and rep
your boys all right
in your hand and your
in your body
and you're everywhere
amazon.com
so last time we ended up kind of talking
about
essentially the process of going to
puberty becoming sexually mature and
what was happening with us and how we
were beginning to understand what sex
was going into high school
uh i think i speak for both of us when i
say that we both did understand what sex
was i did yes and uh were very enticed
by the idea of it
but the other thing that was happening
was
we were getting very serious about our
christian faith like that was something
that was happening
um you know
we didn't i didn't get you got the
pamphlet i didn't get the talk but what
i did get was
my parents were you had me in church and
they had me in a youth group and they
had a good idea of what was being taught
in said youth group and they were
talking our youth pastors were talking
you know pretty directly and explicit
not explicitly but directly about sex
and so
it wasn't like we were just walking
around having no idea what we were
supposed to be doing they were going
they were taking the the steps to
connect what was being said in the bible
with like okay but what does this mean
for 1990
kids
and and we were just soaking it up it
was very much don't have sex until you
get married
and here are the reasons why a lot of
which i've already gone over
i remember we talked about but then how
far is too far
you know we'd be given books and we'd
have conversations about well you and
it would be analogies like well don't
you know if don't get so close to the
edge of a cliff that you might fall off
you want to stay back from that cliff a
good number a good number of yards at
least in order to protect yourself from
what what might
what might be near that cliff which
would be an i guess an accidental
falling over and the campaign around and
so it was like don't do anything if you
can help it but the campaign around like
keeping you from the act of sex
you covered a lot of that with sort of
the spiritual stuff and sort of the
biblical framework that was added on i
would say the other piece of this
is something that was very common which
is
there was this sort of information or
might i say misinformation that was
added on to it from a practical
perspective things like
condoms are not effective right like
it it wasn't like okay well condoms are
like 99 effective when used properly it
was like no no no
condoms are not effective
condoms are not the answer in fact the
hiv
virus
can which is repetitive it's like saying
atm machine i understand could go
through right through a condom because
it's so small
things like that that are actually not
true
that you begin to absorb you're like
well my friends are my friends are
having sex using condoms but i already
know that like basically they might as
well they might as well be having sex
without condoms because i know that
those are not effective like it was that
sort of misinformation that began to
take place uh even things and this was a
little bit later that we started getting
this information but the idea that even
the birth control pill
was
capable of inducing abortions do you
remember this oh yeah
um i actually
held on to this belief well into even
the beginning of our marriage it's the
reason that jesse didn't go on birth
control pills
was because it would present it would
prevent implantation of the fertilized
eggs in the wall of the placenta and
since life began at conception
the prevention of implantation of a
fertilized egg in the lining of the
uterus
that itself it is a form of abortion
which is murder right that was so i
didn't have to worry about that until i
was married we were about we were
engaged but then i real i went to the
library
like i started reading things that's the
only time i've gone to the library and
pulled out medical books and read stuff
and talked to my and then took that to
my pastor at the time
and basically
i was just
losing a lot of sleep over that yeah and
just wait you know just trying to get my
pastor to tell me you know what
it's actually you can go in birth
control it's okay right uh we but we
didn't we used condoms for a long time
in our in our marriage yeah we that's
all we used up until like
a few years ago when we got i got a
vasectomy because by that point it was
like what you can go on the pill now
exactly yeah the reasons changed but we
waited all that but we waited so long to
have sex without a condom that's yeah
the other well we can come back another
thing another thing was the idea that uh
if you have sex with somebody you're
having sex with everyone that they've
ever had sex with
you know in terms of uh and that's just
not a purity culture thing that's like a
80s and 90s sort of sexual education
thing
um which is not exactly true
i mean there's these cultural constructs
of virginity in general that aren't just
an evangelical or a christian thing
that's like you know
i guess it you could
you could care about that
it could make sense that like oh i want
the first person
i wanted to you want it to be special
you want it
every i think everybody would want their
first sexual experience to be
be special and meaningful definitely not
uh a negative experience but also it it
seems kind of sweet for it to be
in the least sweet to be
their first and your first
or
you know if you have certain opinions
about it's like i don't want to i don't
want to be any i don't be second to
anybody
but the but purity culture really leaned
into that because it said that like
god is there and
this this this is irr
it's implied that it's irreparable yeah
that there's some sort of damage that is
gonna be lasting my application to this
as you getting back to what you were
saying with the you know where do you
draw the line like how do you do this
because we weren't at that point we'll
talk about once we got to college it got
even more explicit and straightforward
in terms of being advised as to what you
should do and what you shouldn't do
we were still a little bit on our own we
knew we shouldn't have sex and we knew
that it was they would say it's like
lighting a candle it's like lighting a
fuse and once you light the fuse the
bomb is going to explode right so don't
even light the fuse meaning like kissing
right well or that was what i'm saying
potentially dating it was up to your own
interpretation at that point yes for me
i did a little bit of like internal
thinking on this and
i came up with my own standard and my
own standard was okay it feels like
um i can't get aids
from boobies
and i can't get a girl pregnant by
messing with her boobies
um now i also want to preface this with
the fact that i did not have a lot of
opportunity as much as i liked women
i did not have a lot of success with
actually
convincing any of them to be in a
relationship with me there was you know
it happened a few times but it wasn't
like i was a casanova by any means
but in the few relationships that i did
have in high school
i think and again it's implied but i'll
say it just because
consent was always
a part of this it was not something that
was doing to someone it was something
that we were doing together but i think
that a lot of the girls may have been
like wow
he's really into boobies he must be a
boob man
and it's like well i'm not really you
know i mean i like him
i'm not a boob man that was you going
all the way but it was like all your way
that's as much
sex as i could have at the time
and so there was a lot of focus on the
boobies
probably excessive
uh but it was because i had drawn this
imaginary line at the waist okay that
was my that was my application to that
but you weren't having conversations
with your girlfriends to to like
like about those boundaries no at that
point i wasn't saying and it was a it
was certainly a corrective thing you
know i'm not really i'm not really a
boob man but
i'm gonna seem like one i know i wasn't
having those conversations but this was
a this was a tightening up of your of
your standards from
yeah the previous episode yeah i had
done more at a church lock-in than i was
willing to do
later once once my own personal
standards started i started like kind of
waking up and saying oh no i'm heading
down the wrong road and listen we were
involved in a you we were really tight
with our our youth group within our
church and then we go to high school and
we all started you know dating people
but
you know the people from our youth group
and like there's like this oh
they're they're keeping an eye on us
we're keeping an eye on them there's
like this built-in accountability like
well you know that we were kind of all
praying together at our church meeting
and like agreeing that like yeah true
love waits
and we're gonna stay as far away from
temptation and sexual immorality as we
can
so
there were other people from other other
schools and other churches and
who who were doing different things and
it was easy to say we are not like them
we are we're going to serve we're going
to serve god we're going to we're
serious about this
and
if you really love god and he's inside
of my body like
like
i need to
i need i need to honor that and i'm
serious about it and we were serious
about it we increasingly so i mean when
we started the band the wax paper dogs
it was a christian rock band we would we
would like preach from the stage like
give an invitation
all the songs were written about
uh
your relationship our relationships with
god in very in one form or another very
weird ways very weird 90s alternative
rock ways
but we kind of set ourselves up
first with the youth group and then and
the mission trips we would go on and
just our identity was very wrapped up in
our our christianity and then in in
being in a band and inviting all of our
friends to our concerts by the time we
were in our junior year of high school
i mean we kept holding ourselves to
higher and higher standards we couldn't
be going around having sex with our
girlfriends because it would be super
hypocritical but what we could do and
what i was doing regularly was
masturbating right which again we had
not
really started to talk about now what we
what we
what we did know
is that you know jesus said that even
when you just look upon a woman with
lust you might as you basically have had
sex with her in your mind like you're
guilty in the same so
christians take that verse which i did
not quote i just paraphrased and they
say basically this is why masturbation
is wrong because in order to masturbate
there's got to be a lustful sort of seed
of a thought that you're acting upon
right and so masturbation is seen as
sinful in most especially back in the
day but most christian circles so and
then when it's when it's something
that's wrong
it's something that needs to be
confessed because anytime you sin
you are putting you're building a
barrier between you and god
that then
the way you remove that barrier is you
you confess your sin you acknowledge
yes i did this i mean in catholic
circles they'll go to a priest in the
closet or whatever they call it but we
would just do it in the privacy of our
own bedrooms every night before i'd fall
asleep i would say all right i need to
clear the slate of everything i did
that i know of and i'll also confess to
stuff that i don't even know i did just
blanket confession
in order to remove any of that barrier
so that
i can still
have a relationship with god and so that
and then i guess that starts to bleed
into so that i can be good or so that
i can experience the benefits of that
whatever it is making those connections
as much as i was like you should you
shouldn't be doing this and you should
feel guilty and shameful when you do it
to the point that i actually remember
writing on my ceiling at a popcorn
ceiling yeah in my room and i was able
to write on my ceiling in pencil as i'm
lying in bed i can look up and see it
and i wrote you better not really yeah
you better not better not
masturbate and didn't write masturbate
because i knew that's what i was talking
about
and
so that work
hell no it didn't work i mean
i mean yeah it would here's the thing
better not i was this is where we're
going to talk a little bit about shame
because the thing that was happening
for me
is that you begin
to operate in secrecy because at this
point we'll talk about college in a
second but at high school we were not
confessing to each other or other people
about masturbation we were just
struggling with it on our own feeling
horrible like
the moment that you're done
the clarity that comes right
comes is probably not the right word the
clarity that arrives
um i guess there's an evolutionary
reason for that that's like oh you
better get your wits about you and just
be ready to defend yourself yeah or
something um but the clarity that arises
accomplished
when you're an evangelical christian or
just someone who just believes that
masturbation is wrong that's where the
guilt comes in that's where the shame
comes in and you keep it to yourself and
then you go back to the struggle and it
hits you like a
like a brill
it's like it's like back up the truck
and i mean sometimes you get to a point
where it's like you
i mean you would know
it's you're just seconds away from just
being hit with
the shame and guilt of it yeah but it
wasn't
i mean and then that might be enough to
say i'm pro
i would say i promise i'm never going to
do i'm never going to do it again i
don't want this to be the reason that
we're that i can't talk to you god and
that i i love you more than this but
what you're beginning to do what you're
beginning to do then a few days later
here here we are again because it was it
was such it's biological that's what
happens yeah that's why you're back
there not because something's wrong with
you but irresistible instinctual draw
you're a human with sexual desire now
and you're also of an age when from an
evolutionary standpoint you would have
been
using these tools to to
propagate the population i mean that's
just his biological history of but we
didn't have any tools to
to cut ourselves any slack because there
was no
communication the only person i was
confessing it to was god yeah and then i
knew that there was grace and
forgiveness technically
but i just but i knew
what it what it meant i think the bigger
thing that was happening i think to god
the the thing that became became a
long-term thing that i feel like is
still a part of
my brain today
is that in a
yeah you know i read an article recently
i'll make the connection to this in a
second about some urologist was saying
here's why you shouldn't pee in the
shower it's like well i got hoppy in the
shower on a pretty regular basis let me
read this
and he was like the reason you shouldn't
be in the shower is because you're
basically reinforcing this pavlovian
response of feeling water on your body
or hearing the sound of water making you
want to pee and so this is going to
become
more difficult because you're
associating this sensation with needing
to release the pee i don't think that's
that big of a life problem if you hear
running water and you need to pee i
think you'll be okay
but when you think about when you are
masturbating thank you for letting me
off the hook with that when you're
masturbating in this uh purity culture
framework
what you're doing is every single time
that you are experiencing sexual
pleasure
you are heaping the most intense
portion of shame that you have is
available to you onto that and
associating shame and sex together wow
that is not something that you easily
get rid of no well first of all i'll say
now it makes a whole lot more sense why
whenever i hear running water i jerk off
right exactly uh-huh that's i was hoping
you had made that i mean the shower
is the place to be well at least at
first i mean that was what that like my
mom's not gonna walk in the shower
and catch me right and so i was really
concerned about that
especially after leaving the victoria's
secret out last week but i mean you know
but you don't want to get soap and you
don't want to get soap in the
urethra that can cause problems yeah if
you were to if we were training notes i
could have learned that the easy way
the other but the point that you're
making is that yeah you you associate
shame
with that with that experience with with
a pleasure
and also an exercise in self-discovery
you know masturbation is an important
part of self-discovery that leads to
empowerment
of
and control of yourself whenever you're
you start to engage sexually with
somebody else it's like you you know
what works and you first of all you
don't
require anybody else all right there's a
there's a line in the first wonder woman
movie that basically says that
you know i don't have to have a man to
experience pleasure i don't know how
exactly she said it but i was like i i
love the fact that she that that was a
part of the movie
let's keep going there's there's more
masturbation talk to be had but yeah
yeah
well the other tiny point that you're
making now about it well the the other p
i mean obviously there are some
neurological things that i don't fully
understand that are happening as well
when you're associating so much shame
with sex
you're you're putting things into your
brain that you can't just get rid of
it's not if there's a physical
manifestation happening in your brain
tissue when you do those kinds of things
but the other thing that was happening
was i was continuing to look at porn
and um
that this is an inch
there's an interesting evolution of what
was happening
just with porn and the internet in
general that we happen to live through
like as we were literally maturing and
going through adolescence the nature and
the availability of porn was going
through like we were right in sync with
these monumental changes that you had to
be you basically have to be about 43 44
years old in order to relate to this
because it was
very
clearly just physical magazines that you
had to have of source in the woods you
had to go to the woods you had to go to
the grock and work for a dollar an hour
to just look at porn in the bathroom you
had to find the porn
but then in high school there were a few
rich kids who had compute
who had computers
that had an internet connection
and at this point
you you basically could look at pictures
not videos talking the mid 90s pictures
of porn on the computer
and now you had to have a friend which
we had a mutual friend i'm not gonna
name him and i don't know if you ever
partook
but he was my source for both
additional porn mags that i would he
would be like i'm done with this one i
would take it
i would take it home
i would put it under my mattress now i
had porn
like on standby
in my own bed oh in the bed where the on
the ceiling says you better do it you
better not
you better not pull that porn out that
your friend gave you but the other thing
that i bet it was like the princess and
the pee you could feel that porn just
under that mattress well i could put the
magazine
in front of the you better not
and just look at the boobies and not
have to worry about that you better not
i eventually i did i never got any of
this
like it was never offered to me and i
never asked for it and i never i never
got it well and we never talked about it
i was i was ashamed of it but i was
going you know i mean we looked at porn
together at the grock but
yeah i i don't know
we kind of took turns in the bathroom
yeah so not really but at that point we
were a little bit more serious about
things and this friend was not a
christian
and you couldn't tell me because i would
be like you got you you better not yeah
but
the thing but then his computer
which it was funny because it wasn't
like we went to a website i don't think
i understood what a website was in like
1994
but what i did understand is he was like
i've got this folder of all the pictures
that i've downloaded
because you had to wait a freaking f and
he didn't have any shame about it you
had to wait five to seven he was like
i'm done with this or hey here's my
folder right to get a high-res picture
you had to wait five to seven minutes
and it would like slowly
unfold but oh there's the nipples
okay like a dot major there's the bottom
of the booby all right how long is it
gonna take to get to the vagina
you know it's like because i'm waiting
for it because you know that's what i'm
waiting for because that's what i'm
about yes right
i think i established that in the first
episode but
that wasn't good enough so he's like
listen i've gone through the trouble of
downloading all these you can just look
at them
and uh
sometimes he would be there and
sometimes he knew i needed my own time
oh gosh no but i did not no to be clear
just you know you might already think
i'm a freak and a creep but i did not
then
masturbate at this dude's house just so
you know i just kind of took these
images in my and implanted them in my
brain and then took them
back home but that there was a lot of
that happening like seeking out those
opportunities which we're still
we live in a completely different world
now
where you have access to it and it's
it's explicit and it's any sort of
flavor that you want and it's on your
phone at any time
which will get into like what that might
mean and what that might be doing to
society or our opinion on that at this
point it was still difficult to access
but it was still this thing that i was
like i wasn't in any relationships where
i was sexually active i wasn't going to
do that with an actual woman
for two reasons number one i didn't have
much opportunity and number two i was
pretty good at holding myself to the not
below the belt standard in any
relationships i was in
but it felt different i was like well i
can go and kind of
literally release a lot of this tension
by looking at porn and masturbating and
so that's what i kept doing even though
i felt
horrible every time it happened for me
in high school i mean i
i was i was just frightened of
conducting myself in in a dating
relationship
and so
i i never worried about i might have sex
with some girl i knew that wasn't going
to happen but even the physical
relationship it was kind of like a high
school was kind of like a reset for me
the few girls that i dated right at the
beginning i was just so in my own head
like i couldn't kiss them i got dumped
because i didn't want to
want to want to kiss a girl who really
wanted to kiss me
um i did
eventually dabble in
physical relationship with i guess a
couple of girls i dated and it it was a
cycle of
is this okay
do i feel guilty i'm just going to
confess to god anyway but it wasn't
i would i just wasn't i still i still
was had so much trepidation that it
overrode
most of my drive
i got in a serious relationship
my senior year of high school
and that's
that's when i mean it's like
we were in love with each other and it
was really serious and it was going
really well and
then within the safety of that
relationship
all of the our physical relationship
progressed
and
yeah it progressed further and further
and of course we were in the we were in
the band we were preaching from stage we
we would talk as a band when we get
together and rehearse
we would have like
basically accountability and if you're
if you're not from the evangelical
movement you hear that word and you know
what it means but it means something
more specific within
our world it's a little it's more
systematic and it involves
saying
like there's
you say what you need help with and then
you basically
when you get together with your
accountability partners then they start
they'll ask you questions you've given
them permission to ask you questions
about it to hold you accountable that
you're keeping your commitments you
better not
so
i have to think
well
i don't know if we talked about
masturbation
in those meetings
i i don't think we did i don't think we
were comfortable enough but we talked
about like i'm struggling in my
relationship with my girlfriend like i
want to make sure that like i'm honoring
god
and we were just so serious and we had
we had put ourselves out there
that like if if if we were hypocritical
then
it might ruin someone's chances of
coming to coming to jesus
we're very serious about it and i
brought that
into
this very serious dating relationship
but we were making out and trying to
just stop it at that
so so my line was at the collarbone whoa
yeah wow that's where mine should have
asked me where the line could be that's
where my line was and that line has a
tendency to move down i would say i
remember we we were having conversations
but you had had girlfriends earlier and
then your the well kind of dried up for
you like by senior year you weren't
dating anybody right not senior year
junior year yeah but not senior year i
remember we would we would hang out in
the walmart parking lot and we would
talk about like we would talk about the
like the hypocrisy that's on the line we
would encourage each other to be
chased and you're like man i've you know
you would talk i think you would talk
about your line and you would tell me
about some of the things that you had
done
and then we would encourage each other
not to do those things and then within
the band we were really we were trying
to do that too because the band was kind
of on the line
in this if i screw up
literally
in my with my girlfriend
does the band fall apart you know and
does my relationship with god fall apart
i mean one thing i will say about us
um is that we we have always been and i
actually think this is the thing that
drove our deconstruction
um
we have always been pretty concerned
about truth and integrity like you know
uh it's it's it is something that has
the idea
of saying this and doing something that
was different and not representative of
that thing
was something that we couldn't really
live with so it was it wasn't just this
sort of pressure of the culture that we
were in because listen there were lots
of christian kids who were part of that
same culture and were like guys you
actually you mean you take you you
literally take this seriously i'm
screwing my girlfriend i mean of course
i know i'm not supposed to but i'm not
gonna not do it but we were like no no
you like
you can't do that thing because it's
wrong and you're not supposed to do it
and it would ruin your witness if you
were to if you were to do it and i don't
hold i mean i think that that's that's a
i'm proud of us in that way yeah um
because i think that we took it very
seriously it was the framework that we
had committed to and it came with
consequences and it came with
standards that were you're supposed to
follow
you know and at certain points they felt
impossible
i mean
and
so there were there were times when
when i if you're making out with your
girlfriend when i was making out with my
girlfriend it would get you know
it your collarbone gets old your body
kind of takes over because your body is
telling you
what it wants and you can find yourself
doing things that it's it's it's almost
like an out-of-body experience
especially when it is such an
existential crisis like you're
i'm i was
making out with my girlfriend and i was
having this internal
conflict
and i felt like it was
satan versus
the holy spirit
and it was
don't do don't do this that the cycle of
shame
um with masturbation would have happened
in our relationship whenever we would
cross a line
but we were so infatuated with each
other that
we kept
we would make rules keep doing it we
wouldn't we're not going to touch each
other and then it's like it was just
hard to keep your hands off sometimes
they don't i mean setting that boundary
and drawing those lines it is human
nature to then go and cross the lines so
on a physical level it was a complete
struggle
and
so frustrating
but on a spiritual level it was just as
much anguish if
it definitely more
because every night after i was hanging
out with my girlfriend it would just be
like all right i've got to confess and
make these promises to god and to myself
and
it
it got to our relationship continued
through
my freshman year in college
so every weekend
you know we'd we'd make sure we spent
time together
and
it it was just i look back on it and i
just feel so sorry for us
because
we
it became this obsession like we we were
motivated to
to to connect
but yet and we had all these struggles
and we would slip up and we'd go too far
and then
you know i would be like i
i'm not only sinning against my own body
and god but i'm i've i feel like i
should be stronger
and i should keep now i'm dragging her
down too
i'm because
every time i did something it put up
that wall of separation with god that
then i had to have a conversation
with him in order to tear it down
and after a while it's like god has to
get be getting tired of this
i'm freaking tired of this
you i also think when you're just making
out and you could do it we could do it
for hours and it would be so much
tension
and struggle and then the other way way
i just look i look back and i'm sorry
for us is that like if we had just
gotten it over with we probably could
have had a much more vibrant
relationship but it actually began to
completely define
our relationship because it was
i want to be with you i want to i want
to enjoy you
relationally not just physically
but we have
but the desire is so strong and it's
right and the rules we put in place just
it was
it was torture it was a form of torture
well the interesting thing again kind of
looking at this from a strictly
biological standpoint if you think about
what is actually happening you're doing
something that the two human bodies are
not really
you know have not adapted to do which is
to just live in this foreplay
place
just indefinitely right which is where
the whole i kiss dating goodbye thing
came about which we got more into in
college where it's just like
don't even do anything physical because
and that was a christian application was
you're basically just sitting there with
the end of this burnt fuse just lighting
and lighting and lighting it and it's
getting super old and it's not even that
fun anymore and it feels like all the
focus of your relationship is on not
letting the fuse burn down to the bomb
and blow up right
and but it's just interesting to think
about it in a secular context now to be
like you got these two
sexually mature people who have all the
equipment and all the hormones in order
to then move towards
a procreative act
who believe that they shouldn't do that
but are kind of just starting with this
starting in this place that
naturally leads to sex but they don't go
there because of this other
philosophical framework
what is that i mean that's that's a
hellish place to be ultimately what i'm
saying it definitely was and then so by
at a certain point
it it it became this struggle became
such a cornerstone of our relationship
that i began to believe that i it was
creating an insurmountable barrier
like i couldn't confess at a rapid
enough rate
to
to keep that wall between me and god
down and i assumed that i was doing the
same for her or that
again there was consent she was on the
same page
so i she was having a similar experience
it that that defined our relationship to
the point where
we broke up
just because we couldn't handle that
anymore and you know what it did it
absolutely broke my heart
because
we broke up because we were so into each
other that we were doing things that
that
you know were dismantling our
relationships with god it didn't it
wasn't about anything that happened
between us otherwise
you know and i can i i'm i probably
spiritualized it at the time and said
well you know if i can't if i can't be
someone who
keeps my my standards and my boundaries
and also does my part to
to keep her pure as well
then i don't need to be in this i don't
need to do this to her and i don't need
to do this to god
and that's the reason why we broke up
it's really tough to it's like when
it felt like you're really in love with
somebody that you and you think maybe
you want to spend the rest of your life
with them but then it's like okay they
they move away and you don't
and so you break up for some tertiary
reason yeah but you didn't actually have
a
um you didn't have a normal breakup
process of like realizing that you
weren't right for each other there was
some nothing insurmountable
it was like a sort of emotionally
stunted
process because of this other factor it
consumed our relationship and just
like a wildfire i just feel like it it
burned us to a crisp
and so
we broke up
and
uh
that was probably the and i've said this
before i feel like that's the most
prolonged experience of depression
that i've had in my life
except
uh for
uh
parts of kovid and and lockdown um and
so you can see as i
that entire experience
going into my sophomore year and then
like we broke up at the beginning of the
summer before sophomore year and then
the first
half of sophomore year was like this
depression and then i met christy
and
everything from that experience impacted
how i would approach it so
you know
and we laugh about all the things that
and christy and i can look back and we
do laugh when we tell people our kids
and other people or write about it in
the book of mythicality
the things that we didn't do we didn't
kiss until we got engaged well i want to
stop all of that type i want to stop you
there just because one of the things
that's hitting me i'm going to throw
this out there to you is that we haven't
even gotten into the college experience
which was a completely different level
of focus being in campus ministry and we
haven't talked about what it's like to
be people who come from that environment
and then get engaged and try to keep
from having sex with your fiance during
that i feel like
we've just crossed the our
threshold here we're going to go either
we're going to go another hour and this
is going to be a two-hour episode
or we can make this episode of
two-parter and just september it becomes
five episodes i think the next episode
we're going to be having the same
conversation
so all of a sudden you're talking about
well but i think we're gonna be talking
a lot about
you know
uh
when we finally had sex or our wives are
gonna be talking about when they finally
had sex we're gonna be talking about
parenthood we're gonna be talking about
sex within marriage i mean i listen i
think sex timber is just too much to
contain in september in september i
think sex timber lives in september but
then the q a
actually reaches out into october
i mean i think that's what's happening
it's like the sex cannot be contained
there's just so much of it we haven't
even gotten a cop we haven't even gotten
to college and i don't want to give that
short shrift because
my i got to tell the whole reason that
me and jesse became boyfriend and
girlfriend which is largely related to
the standards that i had set and how she
didn't even understand them like there's
a lot to unpack and i just think that
you gotta give it its own pace all right
i think that's fair um
so what so what is your take away from
from from this because i feel like i
might be saying since we have some more
time now
if i go back to that high school
relationship i don't know there's part
of me listening to myself and saying
well if you just put more boundaries in
place like you would have a better
relationship it's like you're you're not
the victim here you're the problem i
think and that's definitely what i felt
at the time i
strongly believe that if someone is
committed to an evangelical worldview
then they will use
the stories that we tell
to uh reinforce their position right
again our our point is not to make you
question what you think it's just we're
giving you our perspective
i think that
your story about your relationship where
you got to this place where it became
consumed by trying to hold each other
holding hold yourselves back from each
other physically to the point that you
couldn't even have a real relationship
and you and it literally killed your
relationship
to me like i was saying earlier that's
the reason that the whole josh harris
ikis dating goodbye movement happened
because it was a recognition that like
hey
the whole problem is dating the whole
problem is relationships like you've got
these people who are
uh you know ready to have sex and and
everything about them is geared towards
having sex with each other
you just shouldn't be in a relationship
and that's where dating became a bad
thing and the idea of courtship became
the thing that we started talking about
in the late 90s and early 2000s it was
the idea that
you really shouldn't engage romantically
with someone until you're in a place
where that process will over a
relatively short period of time actually
lead to marriage and the consummation of
that physical relationship and so that's
where the idea of having your parents
involved in the courtship and helping
you think through this and you know the
whole idea of like spending time on the
front porch with a girl that you might
be it's the old way of thinking about
things right
spending time on a front porch and
seeing if you and your families get
along and are we right for each other
and if we are right for each other let's
begin dating or let's begin courting
with the idea that we're moving towards
marriage and
we're not we're moving towards that
physical relationship then we know that
it's going to happen we're getting ready
to set a date really quickly so you
don't end up in this place where you're
just burning the end of the fuse all the
time
now here's what i'll say
i think that the whole i kiss dating
goodbye movement did irreparable damage
to a lot of different people and by the
way josh harris recognized that and went
on a whole like you know apology tour
and he senses deconstructed and i don't
know josh and i don't know his story and
i'm not speaking on his behalf but he's
taking the book out of print he quit
printing the book yeah
i think and i think a lot of people
recognize that that mentality was
actually not an effective way to really
meet the needs of young men and women
but
you understand why it happened
it happened because of the story that
you just told is a story that was
happening with so many young people i
mean and there's totally different type
applications like you hear about the
the the back door policy where it's like
we didn't know about garfunkel and oats
yeah where girls won't give the they
feel like
they're dating a guy that they have to
give them something so
so they have anal sex instead of vaginal
sex
and then that's okay because that's the
loophole yeah
literally that was the joke in their
song um
for
yeah for for putting them in a position
where it's like well i got to conduct
this relationship and i but i got to be
i got to be right before god
you know i mean there's all types of
horror story applications where it's
that aren't our stories well and i mean
you talk about someone who's queer and
they're coming to grips with that
let me just acknowledge we we're talking
about all this within a very strictly
heterosexual context
because that's our
experience if you were you know
anything other than that
going through this environment this
evangelical environment like
you there what there was they weren't
writing a book for you you know there no
one was even wanting to talk to you
about it like if you if you were like
and the way that we would have said it
struggling with same-sex attraction
struggling right like that's how the
evangelicals framework puts it is like
that is just strictly a sin and that's a
whole different thing that you got to
deal with in a different setting whether
that's like you know now we got to pray
the gay away or whatever
so we acknowledge that we're not talking
about that but that's a very real and
and by the way
much more difficult experience than just
trying not to screw your girlfriend
uh
not having had that happen to me i i'm
just saying i can imagine that being in
a place where
your very sexual identity is not even
acknowledged as anything other than a
sin
like because the the benefit and the
privilege of being
you know a heterosexual person in this
context is like
the youth pastor would say listen your
desire for your girlfriend is good
it is natural
and one day you will be able to
consummate that physical relationship
but it only should happen in the context
of marriage so you've got to so again
your desire is validated if you're queer
your desire is invalidated yeah which is
a completely different amount of damage
that happens uh in the in the christian
context a lot of times there were so
many ways that we were spoken to in
order to just it's like well it was kind
of like try this analogy on try try the
anything that would keep you from
from slipping up
you know it was they would just invent
all it's not easy and but like i
remember thinking when i was making out
my girlfriend is like if she's not my
wife
my future like picture
there was like
advice to picture your future
partner
picture your wife of the future
and what you're what you're robbing her
of by doing this now and i was like
maybe i'll try that this is someone's
future wife
what if this was my sister well i
probably wouldn't be kissing her
well i you know the interesting thing
we'll we'll get into a couple episodes
from now
is that
you know
this is not a problem that is only being
[Music]
addressed by the evangelical community
right yeah we live in a culture
where
uh again the the biology
is such that
you're basically you know you go through
puberty at what 12 13 14
and then if you've if you've rewind 10
000 years
at that point in like your early teenage
mid teenage years you're basically
pairing up or maybe getting into some
sort of polyamorous relation you're
having sex at that point right that's
just that's why the sexual maturity
happens at that point because from just
a pure biological standpoint that's when
you're ready to right but cul a cultural
framework
apart from any sort of christian ideas
has been put on top of that where it's
just like hey you know
you definitely as a 15 year old in the
year 2021 shouldn't be going out and
making babies right like just culturally
this is not the way that we're doing
things right now people don't get
pregnant when they're 15 for a lot of
really good reasons so
you have to deal with that like there
has to be an answer to that because the
answer is not do whatever the hell you
want to and deal with the consequences
because the consequences of sex continue
to be stis which continue to get even
more and more scary
with just the way viruses and bacteria
evolve
but also unwanted
or just so i could just say team i could
just say pregnancy right
uh so
you have there is there's got to be a
framework
just because we're not christians
anymore doesn't mean that we don't have
a framework
for trying to address these things
personally and for our families it's
just
the underlying framework
changes right but the intention the
intention of like we kind of want people
to avoid
the these risks is sort of the it is the
underlying motivation
and you just we have experience with
this very
specific expression of that
and all these oth this other mess that
got put on top of it where it's like we
got to get the we got to get the shame
on top of this we got to get the guilt
on top of this and then you you just had
to you know i didn't have
i wasn't in a relationship at that point
in my senior year
it wasn't until later once we got into
college and a whole new set of standards
and a whole new level of accountability
and transparency was put on us because
we got in campus ministry that it began
to impact my relationship
my relationships in college that's what
we'll talk about next time because it
was a it was a whole different world at
that point yeah
yeah so um
we'll we'll get into college i think you
know you can see where this is going
the systems that we had in high school
and
were just amped up
on on a collegiate level
and the things that we put in place
the systems that i put in place in my
dating life
and
with christy and
all the systems we put in place for
accountability it's just kind of
mind-blowing charts there's charts
charts involved yeah if you're
interested in charts so yeah i'm glad
i'm sorry to uh to frustrate you to give
you uh listening blue balls so to speak
uh push half of this to next week's part
of the analogy i don't want to give it i
don't want to give our college
uh
experience short shrift because i think
there's a lot to explore there and as we
keep going i guess we're
i i want to fully process this well
we're slowly revealing we're slow it's
just like striptease just like a picture
of a naked lady in 1995 being downloaded
by a like a modem 56k mode 56k modem
we're revealing ourselves to you over
time slowly i've got a
a wreck for you
this is just another gentle nudge
i know you might roll your eyes but you
know what it might be time to pick up
that journal
try try journaling again
i feel like if i just had a
a reminder every six to nine months it's
like you know what why don't you try
journaling again hmm
that's so i'm taking this rec spot
to just say
you know what just try it
you wanna maybe you try journaling again
i'm definitely gonna look back through
my journal and experience some of this
anguish as i prepare for the because i
was generally hot and heavy
in uh
in college oh yeah and so i'll go back
to that uh
with the sex filter on
and see what i can come up with all
right keep the questions coming
hashtag ear biscuits
uh it it extends and i'm talking about
uh the podcast sex timber it extends
it's gonna go through october at this
point or into october
it's gonna penetrate october yeah right
yeah
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]